so I just I just want to say one thing
Thank You Jillian one Jillian can you
rate so i Julianne I just want you to
know that I know it was humming along
but I'm scheduled for 2:00 p.m. and I'm
here on time Jillian tweeted social date
a week was moving right along but Gary
be running late derailed the passing of
the torch now I know that this was
running 15 minutes ahead which is
incredible you guys are crushing it but
I just want to take I don't want to lose
any brand equity that anybody thinks
that I was running late or than I think
I'm so cool to be late for something I
would never do that and so I just wanted
to make that public statement to start
this talk and you know what's
interesting that's probably like you
actually did me a humongous favor so I'm
gonna hug it out with you afterwards
because really what just happened is
actually what I think about when I think
about this whole world which is my
friends we have more than enough data
for the rest of our lives
right like big data is awesome and I'm
all-in
I hear about data every day I think
about it all the time it's how I built
winelibrary.com I launched the
e-commerce wine business in 1996 my
advantage was the fact that I use data
my advantage was that I innovated and
did things before everybody else my
advantage was the fact that I bought the
keyword wine on Google for five cents
for nine and a half months before
anybody bid me up because nobody in
liquor wine retail knew what they were
doing so I've always done this right my
advantages was fast moving collecting
the data and responding my entire
relevance to this space why Robert had
those nice things to say about me is
predicated on one thing it's a site
called summize com how many nerds in the
crowd remember summize com just raise
your hands I'm curious so for the nine
of you you remember summize comm was
really the first twitter search engine
and I was nobody in tech in 2007 when I
jumped on Twitter I had started this
wine video blog show called Wine Library
TV to expand my business again me
innovating jumping on YouTube a couple
months after it launched and I wanted to
reach more audience so I jumped on
summize com
let me just give you my normal day in
2007 come into the wine store then to
give you context cuz I know a lot of you
don't know me I had just run for five
years and taken from a three to a forty
five million dollar business right so
it's a real business we made it you know
as my family
business and I shifted into coming in
the morning spending an hour looking at
the numbers making sure everything was
set for the day and then prepping for my
wine show taping and airing it getting
it online and then spending between 7 to
11 hours a day on summize comm when
Twitter did not have that many users and
searching people saying red wine Pinot
Noir Bordeaux and jumping into every
conversation and creating context right
and so back then it was like who is this
guy they look at my profile they click
on the link which took him to my show
and that was my gateway and my gateway
was very important I wasn't acting like
what I call the 19 year old dude just
because somebody said drinking red wine
tonight I wasn't saying Oh buy it from
winelibrary.com I asked him which wine
right I wasn't trying to close on the
first tweet and I think that's where a
lot of people get in trouble and so
that's what I did and I did that every
day for two years all the time until
there was some sort of scale of
relevance and it gets me to my main
point which is this you can have data
for days and everybody does I run a
social media agency now and we have 25
fortune 500 companies and we have data
we have tons of data we have tons of
access to data I've teamed up with these
guys data since I have data now and all
my users which I'm using very
effectively I have an amazing database
I've teamed up with these guys I have a
full database of everybody who's ever
tweeted at me in the last two years a
personal CRM to my nine hundred ninety
nine thousand followers right that's how
close I am you know and I have them all
and I have the two hundred thousand that
really care and I'm engaged with me and
it's perfectly organized and we have it
structured and have they ever mentioned
the book and how many times and how many
times have I deemed with them and
everything gorgeous clean perfect but
now what I took the entire month of
August off for the most part to spend
some time with the kids but I was
engaging off of that data set I had to
put in the work date is phenomenal and
it's important and a lot of people here
understand it way better than I do and
understand how to structure it but we
have to understand as our data and as
we're getting better at it and as
companies like Zynga and group
and LivingSocial and many others have
figured out angles and ways to run the
data efficiently cost spends what's your
acquisition versus all these great
things that you can do I would say that
data where we are today is an amazing
place for hunting I would say we've
mapped I would even make the argument
that we've mapped hunting for new
customers but the real game is farming
the real game isn't hunting the real
game is farming we're gonna be able to
acquire users we're gonna be able to get
them we have the data on them they're
putting it out for us we can get to them
but now what how do you actually bring
them value to me this whole sector and
this whole mindset is not about can we
get it or how do we get it far majority
of you know it
I just won't walk through that nerd room
there's plenty nerds out there they get
it we can get the data we can get it
clean we can get it to a place of
execution but I implore everybody in
this room collectively to understand
what to do with it next because you can
eat the best at gathering it but if you
don't teach and educate your consumers
or the people that are activating
against that data to know what to do
with it you've lost you can create the
greatest tool of all time but if people
don't know how to use it you've lost and
so I promise you people build things
that in theory are probably in some ways
better than a fork or a spoon or a
screwdriver a hammer and all these
things but unless you go had a story
tell and explain to them what to do with
it those things weren't able to win and
so what I'm passionate about what I'm
spending a lot of time on is what do we
actually do with it once we have it and
now you get into the part that a lot of
people my best friends or my MIT nerds
don't like talking about the humanity of
all this right fine you've got it to a
certain point but now we have to act
human on top of the data and so that's
what I do
I acted human with that tweet right now
it was there for me right and it was
there for me to do something with and I
did it to create context for everybody
in this room but more importantly I
really wanted to make sure she knew that
I wasn't late because that one person
and I'm being serious it's kind of funny
you know what's so funny everybody
thinks scale is sexy and I'm obsessed
with things that aren't scalable that's
where the magic is scales the commodity
everybody can play that game
it's the unscalable where all the money
the magic the upside is right now and so
it
might not be scalable for me to leave
this conference right now and look at
the hashtag and see all of you that
talked about this talk and then reply to
you wink thank you
say hello say oh I'm glad you got to see
me speak for the first time or what's up
or dis down the other thing but that's
exactly what I'm gonna do unless I have
an emergency or something else right not
scalable
but it's the effort that matters from
2006 to 2010 2011 I answered every
single tweet and every single email it's
literally what I did for a living and
then the math beat me it became
unscalable I had children I started to
build another business which is taking
up a lot of my time but the effort of
that and the infrastructure it came
about me building what Seth Godin would
call a tribe and building relationships
with people that care about what you
talk about every time something happens
for example here's a good story
my sister had her first child so I was
out of the pocket for two days because
that was an important family event
somebody during that time tweeted
garyvee you've really sold out I used to
be able to tweet you and you'd answer me
in a minute I believe three times the
last two days you haven't replied to be
hashtag jerk me even though my say
listen this is what loving the
unscalable does me even though my sister
has a baby and I'm sending a lot of time
I'm paying attention to everything I'm
just not responding I'm trying to save
seconds I saw that tweet before I could
get in there and three was 12 minutes
old 700 of my fans dismantled that human
being hey [ __ ] his sister had a
child and all things that look like that
what I think people are grossly under
estimating especially in the context of
this conversation where there's a lot of
technical thinking there's a lot of
efficiency thinking there's a lot of
great stuff because by the way it's all
EQ and IQ that's what the whole world's
about it's never but the guys the world
is gray there's no black and white right
and so like you have a whole world that
I hate cuz I'm in the agency world now
where everybody thinks it's about
creative like you have a great idea and
you win some award in France and that's
gonna make it happen and then that's
horseshit and then and then you've got
this world where I can get more around
it because it's so quantifiable evidence
right you do the right thing
and the resultant it's just math and
math is poor right but the problem is
there's a comma after that moment
and that's where the humanity and the
other side come in and so we need to be
thinking about is we can lead the horses
to the well we can build the best
products we can have the cleanest data
but they have to act on it right like a
basketball is perfect right but if you
can't put it in the hoop it didn't do
much for you and that's really important
for us to always remember because all of
us are vulnerable to how people act on
our data all of us and so what we need
to start understanding of the world we
really live in and in a world where data
is really clean and great and very noisy
people are getting pounded more
efficiently I am thrilled that now most
of the advertisement that I see is wine
centric or about the New York Jets or
about Lionel Richie you know I'm happy
he's underrated I'm happy that they know
my interest I'd prefer it I don't like
going to espn.com and seeing whiskey ad
I don't drink whiskey I know I'm my
eighteen to forty year old dude but I
don't [ __ ] drink at ESPN right I get
it so I'm glad that it's getting more
targeting this than the other thing but
the fact the matters there's a ton of
noise we're living in an ad D culture
the way to break through and get to
somebody comes at this speed how do you
get to them how do you get to them so
yes you can get to the data you can
leave me as a business or an advertiser
an entrepreneur to that moment you can
get me there but then I have to know
what to say right data is an amazing
gateway to attention attention is the
holy grail of selling a story but not
knowing what story to tell in the
context of that moment is why most
people fail and more importantly even if
they're good at that part we have to
understand that we are now in a living
and breathing 24/7 365 society where we
need to have deliver value to people in
many different ways at all times and so
what do we do with our data you know
because you can give me data that my
customer it's their birthday right I can
know it's their birthday but what do I
do next do I send them an email with
free shipping on [ __ ] that day hey it's
your birthday Johnny free shipping on us
when free shipping has become a
commodity right I mean things were
moving
we have to evolve right 1999 I did free
shipping for winelibrary.com it was the
first time I did it to this day it's one
of the top 10 selling days in the
history of my company back then we were
a four million dollar company now were
sixty million dollar company still top
ten day you know why supply and demand
nobody was really doing it this was pre
Amazon Prime people were buying wine
that day like the wine had the cure
inside of the bottles right me living in
this Thank You economy that I kind of
live in the gray one guy ordered like 30
cases and in the notes that said I'm
thank you for doing this Wine Library
I'm buying this wine for my daughter's
wedding me you know like we was so busy
I didn't sleep for two days and we were
a small company so I was packing orders
serendipitously I got that order with
that gift note so I stepped away when in
my office and I called him and I said
Jim thank you so much for ordering 20 30
cases of wine I mean that's a lot this
for your daughter's wedding it's amazing
I said I'd like to send you a nice
bottle of champagne in addition on me
tell me where I can send it right this
is where you guys think the story ends
gets way better he goes oh no no no Gary
my daughter is 12
I said what he said yeah my daughter's
12 years old but this deal is so sick
I'm gonna put this wine and keeping the
cellar until their wedding day now now
all of us all of us here us cynical
shoppers we don't buy [ __ ] unless it has
free shipping right cuz the game changed
the great work that a lot of people and
a lot of companies and this company are
doing is gonna make data incredible and
it's gonna give marketers and
entrepreneurs an ability to drive even
new experiences better experiences but
then marketers ruin everything and it's
going to become a commodity once people
understand and so what we need to
understand is this there is a two-prong
attack to all this so building great
tools is great but we need to learn from
the companies and I'll give you a good
one a great company for a lot of the
tech companies in here because I'm
trying to talk to different groups in
here is a company like buddy media right
like they haven't forget about the fact
they had a big exit their product was
dramatically behind their story and even
more importantly behind their service
and there's a lot to learn from that and
I think we should really think about
that which was we could build great
tools we can do all these things but to
me the game is the execution what do you
do with that point of purchase what of
that moment in time that date that event
and we have to start really having that
argument I ironically today is such an
interesting day for me this has been my
whole game for about two years now I'm
pounding this conversation of IQ and EQ
I'm gonna eat you guy I want all my
business in my life based on I
understand people and customers so I
mean you know like that's who I am right
I failed math right like I'm but I built
an e-commerce business and a very
special day happened let me tell you a
quick story about 2001 2001 one of my
developers comes in and goes Gary listen
real quick he said um if we change the
Add to Cart button to orange we're gonna
get a 22% increase in sales and I looked
them and I said get out of my office
nerd stick to what you know and he goes
I thought you'd say that he goes I've
been a be testing it behind your back
and I said get the [ __ ] out of my office
and he left this was just where he left
that's why I said but he was my boy you
know
kind of joking I think I went in the
bathroom washed my face look myself
directly in the mirror and said the
thing that you're great at is about to
become more commoditized because there's
another way to do it and from that
moment on I always respected data and
other things as part of the equation not
the only part the problem is in the
world that I live in you know with the
agency side especially being tech and
social you've got this world that values
this stuff so much
it's the game you guys laugh at the
creatives it's silly that you think like
this is math you can't beat us right
over here they think like nerds like who
gives a [ __ ] it's all about like the
pizzazz right like that's fine but like
it's gonna take a long time to change
and then the magics in the middle and we
have to respect it it's ironic today
that I just came from a behance creative
conference and drove uptown and now I'm
here it's really my two worlds that I
have a lot of passion for and I think
the people in this room that can you
know use a funny reference that can like
crossover you know political lines to
the other side and understand the
marriage of these two phenomenons that
are the end result of proper
storytelling in 2014 will win we have to
respect the data but we have to respect
the creative most important the third
part the part that I personally this
little sliver in between the context of
the room that you're in the thing that I
have a lot of passion for and what I do
for a living is I'm trying to story tell
where customers actually are and
customers are actually in their mobile
devices on social networks and so what I
know is that Facebook Twitter Tumblr
Pinterest Instagram they're all very
different what I know is that way too
many people in the world right now think
of social networks as distribution that
you're doing something and you go to
Facebook and do a status update to drive
people towards it that you tweet out a
link towards it that you make an
animated gif on tumblr if you're really
smart but still you have a link towards
it and what I have a lot of passion for
is actually storytelling within it that
Facebook and Twitter and Pinterest and
vine are places that actually tell a
story and that is you guys know the
metrics are actually happening there on
that platform in those confines and so
what we have to do and what you need to
be thinking about from a data standpoint
is how to position the people that use
your products to know how to tell a
better story in the context meaning that
you were gonna act very
differently in a boardroom meeting than
you are at home with your spouse than
you are with your best boys on a fun
weekend you're going to act very
differently in all those places yet
you're still the same person and all
these platforms need that kind of
thinking and awareness and emotional
data to understand not just a black and
white data thank you
I'm sorry zero